hello guys a lot of new footage has been
revealed in new trailers for spider-man
no way home so let's get straight into
it and break down the footage for you
guys the first trailer starts off with
doctor strange saying all right parker
you ready in this sequence there are new
shots of doctor strange and peter which
look to be inside of the sanctum where
they do the spell so for the sequence
where he says all right parker you're
ready i imagine he's talking about the
spell are you ready are you ready for
the spell and peter does look a little
anxious in this scene so i imagine it is
to do with the spell because we do know
peter messes up the spell by
interrupting it moving on we have an
extended shot of mj and peter in
previous tv spots they were kissing and
now in this scene they are embracing
each other so i imagine this scene takes
place before in an emotional scene it
looks like peter is stepping up to do
something big so he's embracing mj i'm
showing his love to her in case
something happens or or maybe he's
getting moral support in the sense of
you can do this you can do this moving
on we have a new shot of peter being
flung towards a moving train which it
looks like he is hit by i imagine this
is the sequence of the doctor strange
versus spider-man fight which we have
been getting a lot of new footage of
recently and later in this video there
will also be more footage of this so
stay tuned for that we then have a new
line of peter saying do it to doctor
strange where she then cast a spell and
then you see some crazy doctor strange
stuff going on now i've got a little bit
of a prediction possibly this scene
where peter says do it to doctor strange
possibly this is towards the end of the
movie and maybe spider-man and doctor
strange have captured the villains again
and they're being sent back to their
home world so this time doctor strange
is actually asking peter are you ready
and then he says do it and then they get
sent back to their home world all this
could be something completely different
who knows so tell me what you think in
the comment section below what is
happening in this scene we then actually
have a little bit of new footage from
electro which one of the shots here
looked very very cool it's of him slowly
coming towards peter who's on the ground
with electricity going everywhere and
then we cut to a new line of electro how
you like the new
now we have some new footage of dr
octopus with some new dialogue sequences
he says what have you done with my
machine and he also says you want to
play games so i think when he says what
have you done with my machine he's
referring to the machine he made in
spider-man 2 which he actually ends up
destroying so possibly before doctor
octopus becomes good and destroys his
own machine he's brought into this new
universe and he's really confused and
he's asking where's my machine obviously
tom holland spider-man has no clue what
he's talking about so he's not giving dr
octopus the answer that he seeks so then
he says you want to play games we then
have some very exciting new shots of
rain goblin apparently green goblin is
meant to be the main villain of this
movie but we have hardly seen any
footage of him so it's very cool to have
some new shots of him in his new shots
we have him on his glider and he's
actually not wearing his mask in this
scene but his new look which you will
have later in the film the new shots
here seem to be from the sequence of
where he froze the pumpkin bomb where
peter tries to catch but fails now for
the next trailer we have dialogue of
doctor strange saying you're ready and
peter's saying i'm ready in return so i
believe this is also from the spell
sequence which we broke down before so
moving on we have a shot of peter
actually gliding using the iron spider
it looks like the iron spider suit can
do more than what we thought it could as
he glides into scene and makes a hero
landing we then have new shots of doctor
strange inspired man here which i
believe is also from the doctor strange
verse spider-man fight we have doctor
strange in the process of casting the
spell and we have a shot of peter making
a land and onto a floating rock and in
the background you can also see all of
the buildings and skyscrapers and to end
off this trailer we have even more
footage of this fight just an extended
shot of the trains that we have seen
previously they're just twisting and
turning and going towards the sky i'm
gonna say the cgi and visuals in this
scene as i've said before just look
really fantastic and i'm really excited
to see more of this fight anyway guys
that's about it for this video so please
let me know in the comment section below
what you think of the new footage and
also if you haven't already please like
and subscribe and turn notifications on
to show your support thanks for watching
guys